he was a popular American author he
wrote the book Think and Grow wit he's
Napoleon Hill and here her top ten tools
for success a definite purpose must be
accompanied by a definite plan for
edutainment followed by appropriate
action now you have to have a purpose
you have to have a plan and you have to
start putting that plan into action and
ladies and gentlemen it's not too
important that your plan be sound it
isn't in fact it's not too important
because if you find that you've adopted
the plan that's not solved it's not
working you can always change you can
modify your plan but it is very
important that you be definite about
what it is you're going after what your
purpose is that must be very different
learn to adjust yourself to other
people's state of mind and difficulties
so as to get along peacefully with them
and to refrain from taking notice of
trivial circumstances in your relations
with other people by refusing to allow
them to become controversial incidents
great people always avoid small
incidents of controversy when possible
if you want the mind to pick up an idea
and to form a habit so that the mind
will automatically act upon that idea
you've got to tell the mind what you
want over and over and over again no end
to it
when mr. Kui came over here some years
ago with his famous formula day by day
in every way on getting better and
better he cured thousands of people but
a very great number more than that he
didn't cure and I wonder if you would
know why
there was no desire there was no feeling
put into that statement you might just
as well blow in the wind as to make a
statement unless you put some feeling
back of it unless you believe it procure
clean neat pocket-sized a notebook or
something on the order of this one here
glue sleeve affair and on page one write
down a clear description of your major
desire in life the one circumstance or a
position or thing which you will be
willing to accept as your idea of
success and remember before you begin
writing that your only limitations are
those which you set up in your own mind
or from your others to set up for you as
to on page 2 of your notebook write down
a clear statement of precisely what you
intend to give in return for that which
you desire from life and then start in
right where you stand now to begin
giving and three memorize both of your
statements what you desire and what you
intend to give in return for it and to
repeat them at least a dozen times daily
and always and your statements with this
expression of gratitude for the
blessings with which you were gifted at
Birth many dominating desire plan or
purpose which is backed by that State of
Mind known as faith has taken over to
the subconscious section of the mind of
acting upon immediately I don't know for
sure ladies and gentlemen but I suspect
if there's a relatively small number of
people in the world that at one time who
understand the principle of faith who
really understands it and know how to
apply and even if you do understand it
if you don't back it up with action and
make it a part of your habit life you
might just as well not understand it
because faith without deeds is dead
faith without action is dead faith
without the absolute positive belief is
dead I don't know how you're going to
get any results through believing unless
you put some action back of that belief
and incidentally if you tell your mind
off enough that you have faith in
anything
the time will come when your
subconscious mind will accept that even
if you tell your mind off enough that
you have faith in yourself as you ever
thought well nice thing it would be if
you had such complete faith in yourself
that you wouldn't hesitate to undertake
anything you want to do in life have you
ever thought what that what a benefit
that would be to you your personality
determines whether people are attracted
to you or shy away from you
it is the show window in which curve you
display your character to the world and
it is the one thing which distinguishes
you from all other human beings it is
your trademark by which if people
recognize you and it is the thing which
determines your success or failure in
selling yourself to life
therefore you should see your
personality just as others see it so you
may improve it where it needs
improvement if you would sit down and
put out an hour-by-hour account of the
actual work that you put in each day for
one week and then an hour about our
account of the time that you waste that
you could devote to anything you want if
you want to do badly enough you're going
to get one of the shock to your life
we're not efficient you don't have three
hours about eight hours to sleep about
eight hours to earn a living then have
eight hours of free time but you can do
anything that you want to do with here
in this country where we live and then
definiteness of purpose makes one more
alert in recognizing opportunities
related to the object of one's major
purpose and it inspires the courage to
embrace and act upon those opportunities
and now we all see opportunities almost
every day of our lives which if we
embrace them an active department could
benefit us but there's a there's
something in us that we call
procrastination we just don't have the
will the alertness the determination to
embrace opportunities when they come
along but if you condition your mind
with this philosophy you'll not only
embrace opportunities but you do
something better what could you do
better than embrace an opportunity make
the opportunity that's so that's the
idea success is something which has to
be planned and success is something
which has to be earned in advance true
there is such a thing as luck but just
remember that lucky
thing you can create for yourself if you
know the rules and follow them just as I
give them to you remember too that
success in the higher brackets of
achievement is something that can be had
only by taking others along with you and
the best definition of success which I
know is this success is the knowledge
with which to get whatever you want from
life without violating the rights of
others and by helping others to acquire
it the very minute that you decide upon
something you know that's what you want
you know you're going to do it all of
these negatives that have been bothering
you they pick up their baggage and get
out and just move out they can't live in
a positive mind can you imagine a
negative frame of mind and a positive
frame of mind occupying the same space
at the same time could you imagine that
no you can because it can't be done and
did you know that the slightest bit of a
negative and mental attitude is
sufficient to destroy the power of
prayer did you know that the slightest
bit of a negative mental attitude is
sufficient destroy your plan whatever it
is you're doing
carrying out your definiteness of
purpose you have to move with courage
with faith with determination in
connection with carrying out your
definite is a purpose whatever the mind
can conceive and believe the mind can
achieve isn't that a profound statement
you will notice that it says nothing
about the need for education but simply
that's whatever your mind can conceive
and believe your mind can achieve now if
you want evidence that the mind can
achieve whatever the mind can conceive
without the benefit of formal education
you all have to remember that Thomas a
Edison conceived the idea of becoming an
inventor and lived to become the world's
greatest scientists in the field of
invention with only three months of
common school education thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because business asked me to so there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of Napoleon Hill
top ten rules you love the most leave it
in the comments we're going to join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon